Hey! You okay lady bug? You good?
I think so
Peter protect the Guardians.
Thanos separated their souls from their bodies
If they're out too long they will die.
I don't know how to fix that!
No, I know you don't. but she does.
Okay stay here!
Aah!
Wake!
Wake up stupid!
Hey!
It's not working!
Well you can do this?! You can do it.
The wizard said you could do it!
I can't!
They're dying.
You have to.
Please...
Don't leave me!
Don't leave me...
Move your face.
It's making me sick...
Wake!
Oow!
Yeah you may have hit a couple things
on the way down.
Not actually my fault.
You're just super heavy.
welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
This is going to be
my breakdown of the New Avengers
infinity saga deleted scene of
spider-man and mantis and Doctor Strange
saving everyone's souls so it gets super
cosmic super weird there's a lot of big
Easter eggs for the cosmic stuff that
they're going to be doing during Marvel
phase four so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel we're doing a giveaway
for that giant infinity saga box set of all
the blu-rays that's where this scene
came from all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with the big cosmic
stuff during Marvel phase 4 so we'll
just break this down top-5 style
starting with number 5
during Avengers infinity war the battle
on Titan when the Avengers and the
guardians were fighting fan OHS they
were going to use this fight to show you
how Thanos is mastery of all the
different Infinity stones was evolving
super quickly they kind of reference how
hard it is to actually use the Infinity
Gauntlet from a mental perspective not
just how much collateral damage you can
soak from the energy rippling off the
gauntlet while it's being used there's a
reason why only a couple of the
characters a couple of the Avengers and
people like tano's are able to actually
wield the gauntlet the reason why
Professor Hulk is the one to wield the
nano gauntlet instead of Thor is because
Thor could soak the damage but his mind
isn't able to make those fine-tuned
calculations the fine to control to snap
everyone back at the exact location that
they were dusted there was also a moment
when the riders were answering all kinds
of funny specific questions about how
the Infinity Gauntlet and the snaps
worked people asked what happened to all
the people who were snapped while they
were flying thirty thousand feet in the
air on a plane or people who are driving
cars or in the middle of doing something
really dangerous did all those people
get snapped back thirty thousand feet in
the air and then just fall to the ground
and splat they said no in their minds
the Hulk knew to snap them back in a
safe place so it just takes a really
powerful mind a really smart genius
level mind to do all that all over the
universe simultaneously so throughout
the battle that's why you see fan o's
using each of the different Infinity
stones separately with really cool
powers one because it looks cool but
also to show you that he's
learning to master each of the different
stones by themselves and then he uses a
couple of them in combination with each
other showing you that he's slowly
learning to use all the Infinity stones
simultaneously which is what happens
when you actually snap someone out of
existence you're wielding all six stones
at the exact same time so during this
part of the fight scene he was going to
use the soul stone to separate everyone
from their bodies the same way the
ancient ones separated dr. strange from
his body into his astral form what she
was just trying to have open his mind
and freak him out a little number for
the twist though as dr. strange tells
spider-man is that if their souls are
left untethered from their bodies for
too long they'll die so Peter literally
has to swing around and grab their
floating souls and bring them back to
their bodies this gets into some crazy
mythology comic book territory and you
can probably see why the Russos chose to
delete this scene it almost raises more
questions than it answers like why is
spider-man able to physically touch
their souls shouldn't they just pass
through physical objects like ghosts did
dr. strange lay an enchantment on him
that enables him to physically interact
with them and that's on top of the fact
that the concept of the soul stone and
its powers are never fully explained
during Avengers infinity war or Avengers
endgame you actually have to read a lot
of the tie-in material to understand the
rules that they established for the soul
stones powers and abilities their
official explanation is that yes
obviously it can control souls but it is
also able to preserve life after death
which is why the soul world exists
within the soul stone that orange cosmic
place that Thanos in Iron Man in the
deleted scene go after they snapped the
gauntlets the writers and the Russos
didn't call this the soul world even
though that's what it is on the set of
the movies they just refer to it as the
weigh station as in a cosmic train
station between life and death it's
exactly like the end of Harry Potter
Deathly Hallows when he's in the very
cosmic looking version of platform 9 and
3/4 talking to Dumbledore spirit between
life and death
within the Marvel Universe the soul
stone captures pieces of people's souls
and keeps them there like echoes of
their souls
that's how Thanos is able to talk to
Gamora as a child and Ironman is able to
talk to an adult version of his daughter
Morgan Stark the Iron Man scene also
kind of requires a little more
explanation because he's speaking to his
daughter kind of in the future but not
in the future like people's souls only a
just within the soul world after they've
died so at some point in the future she
died of old age and then a piece of her
soul remained here an Iron Man is just
connected to it through the time stone
the Russos also deleted that scene of
Morgan Stark in the soul world just
because people in test screenings found
it too confusing and they didn't
immediately know that that was his
daughter that he was talking to I posted
that deleted scene to my channel a while
ago so I'll link it down in the
description but number three after
spider-man brings their souls back to
their bodies mantis uses her psychic
abilities to bind their souls back to
their physical forms this is also one of
those things that seems very complicated
they don't bother to explain we've only
seen some of her powers and abilities
but if it wasn't clear from guardians of
the galaxy - mantis is also half
celestial like Peter quill she's just
another one of ego the Living Planet
many children that he sired found and
then kept around when he saw that her
psychic abilities were useful to him so
mantis is Peter Quill's half-sister they
don't explicitly let you know that
during guardians - but it's implied when
you see them have that freaky funny
PowerPoint presentation of ego doing it
with all those different species one of
them is from mantises species so she's
very powerful but neither she nor Peter
quill have their crazy God level
celestial powers anymore they only had
those in their immortality while ego the
Living Planet was still alive and they
were in proximity to him so yes they
still have celestial DNA but not
celestial powers speaking of which will
see more Celestials during the Eternals
movie later this year so I'll talk more
about the Celestials in the MCU when
they released that trailer it'll be
super weird and super cool number two
after this scene of spider-man and
mantis saving everyone there was a
deleted scene of The Living Tribunal
that's right The Living Tribunal was
actually in Avengers infinity war for a
brief hot minute well right after this
Doctor Strange was going to do the same
thing to Thanos that the ancient one
also did to him right after this he was
going to send Thanos on a cosmic tour of
the multiverse that would have ended
with him inside the super flow layer of
the multiverse to be judged by the
Living Tribunal obviously the ending of
Avengers infinity war would have been
the same so it's implied that dr.
strange would not have achieved his
intended outcome in taking Thanos to be
judged by the Living Tribunal they would
have had to explain
Hinault's either escapes judgment or
defeats the Living Tribunal which is
kind of ridiculous by itself if you're
not a big comic book reader and you
don't know about Marvel's big cosmic
entities the Living Tribunal is the most
powerful guardian of the entire
multiverse and its mission is to protect
the sum total of all the alternate
realities and dimensions from mystical
imbalances
when someone like tano's threatens to
tip that balance it will lay judgment on
people but it really only gets involved
in the biggest highest order multiverse
stuff when someone is only threatening
one universe as bad as that sounds
usually there are lower order cosmic
beings that step in to deal with that
really good example is the Celestials
the Celestials are way lower on the
cosmic totem pole in terms of hierarchy
from the Living Tribunal eternity is the
only bigger and more powerful being than
the Living Tribunal but the Living
Tribunal isn't invincible there are
other Marvel characters that have
defeated it in the comics in the past
but obviously we haven't really touched
on it that much in the MCU so number one
a lot of this higher level
multiverse cosmic weird stuff that was
cut out of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame they're going to be
doing during Marvel phase four the
multiverse is the next step explaining
it for all the casuals that's what's
going on with Doctor Strange two
multiverse of madness Sam Raimi welcome
back to the fold
Wanda vision the new Loki series setting
the stage for multiverse level villains
and time-travel villains like Kang the
Conqueror in higher order cosmic
entities like the Celestials during the
Eternals movie so Marvel phase four is
going to give us a much deeper version
of the cosmic super-weird history of the
MCU going back to the dawn of creation
is going to be really cool here's my big
question for you guys let me know in the
comments what is the big cosmic stuff do
you want them to do during Marvel phase
four and what's going to happen in the next
couple of months is we're going to start
getting the first eternals trailer the
first venom 2 trailer more Morbius
trailers more details on what's going on
with Tom Hollands spider-man crossover
of course I'll be doing videos for all
that stuff but post your video requests
and big questions in the comments below
so everyone click here for my other big
Avengers infinity saga deleted scenes
and click here for my brand-new
spider-man 4 announcement breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!